good merits I think there's many flaws
within the bill even the Cardinal agreed
on the wording of reasonable was flawed
I think they are going to address it
through rules especially the want and
waste which we all agree and the nice
thing about rules is it gives them
flexibility that if one thing doesn't
work they can speedily fix it rather
than having to wait for the whole
legislative process again so I think
this bill should Ito thank you thank you
um what I was going to say as well is
that uh given the fact that he's told us
it's going to happen in rules
anyway I think I prefer to let them
handle it in rules and see where it goes
than to try to pass legislation that may
be flawed and then have to deal with
trying to clean it up in another year um
represent tutor you had your hand up
I'll wave up wave off okay
representative Fox you haven't spoken
yet I'm going to let he might say it
thank you Mr chair does he have the
ability to create rules around the
hunting contest piece or just the want
and waste piece they can create rules
around any part that they they want to
do um they oversee most of the contests
that are currently done as far as like
the deres and such um so they they can
create rules around those as well um
good question
though any yeah representative Harvey so
that was kind of my question when maybe
I misheard but when they were discussing
it I thought that the rules was only
going to ad address the want and waste
and Not the Killing contest which they
might need um help from the legislature
to um definitely ban killing contests uh
maybe I misheard he did not address that
they were going to take up the the
contests in rules yet um but I know that
there is a framework around those that
they can craft rules around whether they
need some extra legislative I think when
they look into it they'll probably come
back and tell us what they need if they
decide to go that route um but he has
definitely promised to deal with the
want and waste which is one of the
things that we all agreed on in this
committee and I I think that I would
love to see what they do with the direct
the new director and the the uh Colonel
and the and the Commission in drafting
those rules and having those public
hearings to find out what they come up
with representative tutor
first yeah I think
uh that that that uh the contest should
definitely be done in Rules by the by
the fishing game I mean that contest
have so many little nuances of you know
of all the little private pools that go
on that I don't think anyone really
cares about that you and I have a pool
on who gets the biggest buck or the
biggest
turkey um and there's you know hundreds
of those kind of pools that go on for
different kinds of things out there and
that's probably the best place to have
fishing game write the rules on rather
than us try to
legisl I I think two
we have to look at you know the scope
because to say during regular season if
everybody's just taking their one
regular deer that you know I got the
biggest one yay that's different than a
killing contest so I think there's
there's a lot of nuance there that we
need to have fleshed out first as well
uh representative Harvey did you have
another comment um well maybe it's a
strange comment but um I actually agree
with everything that you're saying but I
really still can't I am not going to
support the itl motion because I really
think that what you're saying is
addressed in Colonel Jordan's Amendment
and I really would like to see that um
take the place of this
bill noted representative Smith thank
you Mr chairman if they address want and
waste through the rules process which
clearly
defined and someone then goes and does a
killing contest you have want and waste
so that killing contest can then be
overseen by fishing game through the
want and waste in the rules process so I
don't even know if killing contests need
to be regulated directly but they will
be regulated through the want and waste
rules good point representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman as I
was asking questions one thing came out
to clearly that uh the chairman of the
Fish and Game Commission mentioned that
he does not know any contest going on in
New Hampshire and also the cornal said
that that the Fish and Game Commission
is looking into this for any kind of um
uh new rules that they're going to make
so you know I don't think that we need
to make a new law that they are taking
care of it they have the organization
who take care of this kind of item that
we always see it thank
you representative Jacobs thank you um
did they address whether or not the
contests have to be approved if someone
were to hold one no they're not approved
I don't remember hearing anything about
that so for example a club could just
have one so it wouldn't NE they wouldn't
necessarily know about it if it was
happening um right I guess only if they
saw it advertised right um and then I
guess my second point is there was a lot
of support in Banning these killing
contests and so I just I find it hard to
um simply walk away and just say it's
not feasible I would really like to
address it so
thank you representative ulette uh thank
you uh just to to reply to uh
representative Jacobs I I understand
what you're saying and I don't disagree
but more a lot of the testimony we heard
yesterday was on
coyotes and but there's no limit on
coyotes so if someone is having a a
contest in the this 50 coyotes they're
not doing anything wrong legally morally
they are but legally they're not
and that's where it gets a little a
little fuzzy I
think representative Harvey then Khan
well unless they're killing the coyotes
at night and they did testify that a lot
of these contests take place at night
you cannot hunt a coyote at night except
for the certain particular season for
night hunting coyote which ends after
December or starts after December 15th
when deer hunting ends and runs
through end of February I I believe so
but but yes you're right except for the
season for night hunting correct you
can't hunt them at night correct and I
did not hear whether those night hunting
was actually happening during that
season or if they were saying that it
was illegally being done if it's being
done illegally anyway then it's illegal
anyway and they could arrest every
single person taking part of that um
because it is illegal representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman my colleagues
I just want to mention one thing I just
remembered that is when I asked about
those pictures that was distributed
those pictures the you know the person
who was Distributing they should know
that where these pictures came from it
could be 10 years old it could be that
time when they used to do business with
those uh skins and those kind of FS it
could be 20 years ago so you know they
try to you know tell us these are
happening but it's probably it's not
nothing you know it's old maybe 25 years
old thank you representative Durkin uh
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
make one note not uh
everybody although I live and spent most
of my life here in New Hampshire I've
lived down south and I haven't seen any
place in New Hampshire here that I've
ever haunted that has that many coyotes
to begin with that you could kill that
many down south yes I'll agree um I
don't think that's an issue up here like
the colonel said there are no hunting
contests that he knows of and hasn't in
a couple of years Fair
Point representative Jacobs again thank
you um were there any online submissions
for support our
opposition I could tell you that in a
second thank you we'll let uh
representative Harvey look that up does
anybody else have any other questions
what's the bill number or comments it is
589 representative Fox thank you Mr
chair um one quick note representative
KH on the uh when they were mentioning
the crow hunting um just for a point of
reference somebody did cite an ESPN
article that article is over a decade
old so I just wanted to at least put a
time frame along with it that being said
um morally and ethically it is you know
they may or may not be taking place I
know that there was mentioned that that
they do take place um in the state and
people have seen them on social media um
there are times too I I think it
behooves us to get ahead of something
like this if it is indeed a trend which
I I don't know that it
is Fair
Point do you have that for US
representative Harvey I I do um oh
there's a lot
I I okay it would be easier for me to
count the opposers if that I
can
um one two three four 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38
39 40 41 42 43 44 45 46 47 48 49 50 512
okay there are um um 98 online
um they didn't all do testimony but
there's 98 that um gave you know signed
in and of the 98 they all all support
the bill except for five
okay any further comments oh any any
further
comments seeing none I'll let the clerk
call the rooll
and a reminder this is on
itl this is the vote for itl yes um Mr
chairman yeah yes Mr Vice chairman yes
representative con yes representative
Smith yes representative tutor yes
representative
Murphy sorry what was that yes sorry he
was coughing in my ear representative
Aldrich yes representative jerkin yes
clerk votes yes representative
Harvey no representative Fox no
representative lit yes representative
Jacobs no representative oor yes
representative Pearson
yes and stone is
gone that gives us 13 12 sorry 12 yeses
three
NOS it's iffy this is an iffy one for
consent if anybody objects to consent it
will go on the floor consent okay then
this will go to the floor we'll need a
Minority Report from uh somebody okay
yeah yeah and we'll need a majority
report from yes from
tutor and that was thir 123 yeah
123 okay so this is regular calendar
reports to do tomorrow
please and the last one of the day oh
that closes the exec session on 5 89
we'll now open the exact session on
hb22 and uh I have a motion of itl from
rep ulette and a second from
representative
Durkin it's now open for discussion and
I recognize representative
Harvey thank you we sort of had this
thing going um so surprisingly um as
um uh two of the um Commissioners were
speaking I actually AG age with like
95% of what they were saying uh
representative um stole or commissioner
I'm sorry commissioner stole read to us
the duties of uh the commission and
Commissioners a it's right from statute
I even um abbreviated those at the end
of my testimony absolutely agree there
there's uh no um uh I find no fault with
that and they don't change with this
bill this isn't changing anything that
the Commissioners would do they would
still be held responsible for the duties
that are in statute uh just because you
submit a bill doesn't mean oh everything
else you did goes away no you're still
held responsible to what what the
statute says nothing would change on the
duties um or the mission statement of
the commission or the New Hampshire
fishing game um I also agree with them
that the
commission and Commissioners and the
director uh would work hand inand they
they do now they should continue that
this bill doesn't change that
whatsoever you you cannot run a
department if you're at odds between
your board of directors and your
director if you are at odds then chances
are the board of directors can fire the
director and get a new one um so it's
this bill does not change the way the um
the
Commissioners uh consult advise and work
together on that um it also would not he
uh there was testimony that um possibly
this would eliminate public input no it
wouldn't there's nothing in this bill
that says you would not hold public
input although public input is not
required by law except for the sale of
land I don't know of any organiz ation
that does not open up part of its floor
time for public input so that would that
just would not change um what I do
disagree with is um I did not submit
this bill in any way shape or form to be
dismissive or disrespectful of the
Commissioners I've worked with these
Commissioners for the like I like I told
you i' I've gone to Fish and Game
Commission for meetings for for 9 years
I've worked with them for nine years
different ones I've gone to breakfast
with them and to lunch with them I've
been on the phone with them so I I'm not
it was not a bill um as I felt
representative green was trying to
convey that I was trying to be um
disrespectful or um uh dissing The
Commissioners or their work in any way
shape or form it is so difficult for
them to do their work in the pres setup
they have they meet once a month for two
hours can you imagine how long it would
take our house to get anything done if
we worked once a month for two hours it
it it just is so hard for them to do
what they need to do to to complete
their duties and their mission statement
and all this bill is does is simply
allow them a more efficient way of
working so that they can accomplish what
they need to accomplish for for our
Anglers for our hunters and for our
Trappers in New Hampshire not taking
away any rights from hunters and Anglers
and um uh Trappers they have still the
same rights that they have now it's just
a little bit more of an efficient way to
work so that they can get their their
work done um in a reasonable and um you
know it keeps coming back to the word
efficient way that's all the bill is
thank you point taken
um I like the comparison that was
made uh to the fact that the the
commission is like the board of
directors that sits over the
CEO and I can't imagine any company
running well if the board of directors
was advisory only over the CEO not only
do we not have that situation but the
board of directors is is personally
responsible for overseeing the health of
the company in the interest of the
shareholders much like the commission
is making sure that things are run in
the interest of the hunters and
Sportsmen across all of the 11 areas
that they
represent and a board of directors can
take the Extreme Action of being able to
remove a CEO if they need
to we don't have that ability for the
commission but they do have authority
and I think they need that authority to
be able to make sure that the will of
the sport man around the state is what
governs things and not one person who
sits there as a CEO over the department
I really think that that that analogy of
board of directors answerable to the
people overseeing the CEO is what we've
been working with all these years and um
so I'm I'm not in favor of taking away
their Authority and making them advisory
only I think that they need to keep that
Authority um we could debate whether
they should be able to remove a direct
ctor who's
ineffective um right now that's got to
happen with the executive Council and
the governor but um I think in the past
we have seen some ineffective directors
I know that representative Harvey was
here when when I first had to deal with
one of them uh one who stood out in
front of the room and actually told me
um I don't hunt and I don't fish and as
far as I'm concerned having more people
in the woods means more problems for me
to deal with that's the wrong mentality
for a director of fishing game
and uh somebody who's supposed to be
trying to increase the number of
Sportsmen we have out there in the field
should not be of the opinion that more
people out there mean more problems to
deal
with uh so I definitely uh would not
do would not support this bill to to
make them advisory only and if if I was
ever going to support such a thing I
wouldn't do it in the first year that we
have a brand new director from another
state when we don't know what that
director's like and give them full
control of the entire thing so that
being said that's all my piece is
anybody else representative Durkin yes
thank you um I agree with all of that
and one thing I would like to add to
this is if uh you remember clearly the
commissioner uh said that if this bill
uh was passed that uh you would be
getting his resignation resignation the
very next day um they're hard to come by
uh and there may be more uh that would
resign so keep that in mind
thank you anybody else representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman I just
mirrors on what you said regarding
advisory only could you imagine the
commission is closest to the people they
represent the 11 districts or regions
excuse me just like we of 400
represent various towns and we are
closest to the people could you imagine
removing our capacity to have a binding
vote and changing it to advisory only
make that to Senate and then the
governor has
a unanimous decision on what we
represent I but we can also override
that through the appropriate process so
not not not entirely so it's it would be
full hearted to take away that
representative of the people
representative
Fox thank you Mr chair uh representative
Durkin to your point um you know I I I
also wonder what component of that might
be somewhat of an idol threat because I
I do understand their his passion for it
obviously um you know it's but there are
numerous boards that I serve on because
I can't say no to anything ever um but
there are numerous boards that I serve
on where I am in an advisory capacity
but I'm doing it because of um my
passion for the uh the organization as a
whole so um you know I don't doubt what
you're saying and I feel like he's a man
of his word and he would um however it's
you know I I I'm always is um a little
skeptical of things like
that representative Khan thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman you covered all
four corner of uh the things I had in my
mind especially the director just came
in from a new job we like to see that
how she does and everything in future
maybe it happen but right now we are
fine thank you Representative ulette no
wave off I thought I saw your hand
before representative
Jacobs um most of the uh testimony
yesterday was in opposition to the bill
was there any online support oh I forgot
to look that up thank you thank
you well we look that up uh any other
discussion we're doing well TimeWise
we'll still have
lunch do we
that
yeah I wasn't going to go anywhere but I
might actually be able to grab
lunch the line will be less it's true
it's
true okay without counting um it looks
as if there's about as many um people
online um except it's switched in that
most oppose and there
are
um well I'm scrolling really fast so I
can't can't really see but but you know
most opposed yeah three to five is that
good enough for you okay do we have any
other comments if not the clerk may call
the
role and just to remind you this is on
itl thank you Mr chairman yes Mr Vice
chairman yes representative con yes
representative Smith yes representative
tutor yes representative Murphy yes
representative Aldrich yes
representative jkin yes
clerk votes yes representative Harvey no
representative Fox yes representative
lit yes representative Jacobs yes
representative oor yes representative
Pearson yes it's 14 yeses 14 to one this
would normally be consent unless one
person wants to go to the floor with it
no I'm fine okay um I always give that
option whatever the bill and whoever it
is so we will go consent with it then uh
will you do a Minority Report anyway
you're allowed to in case it gets pulled
from consent so that it shows up and
it'll also show up in the in the
calendar yeah yes I can it is your your
point your ability to put your point of
view forward okay can do that so you
you'll have a Minority Report tomorrow
then for that too and let most the
majority
report and that is it I closed the
hearing on
hb22 that ends all of the house bills
from this committee thank you very much
for all your dedicated time and for
dealing with such a long day yesterday
uh I'm sorry we ended up right against
the wall there um but I'm glad we were
able to finish this off now without
calling everybody in for a special uh
hearing just because especially because
we have several people from Coos County
and they would have to drive 2 hours and
45 minutes to sit here for 20 minutes
and then go home 2 hours and 45 minutes
which I think is kind of ridiculous and
it would cost a state money so thank you
very much represent representative
Durkin I'd like to make a motion that
Murphy buys us
lunch I
second okay we are done everybody go
enjoy lunch and we'll see you all back
in session and nothing will happen in
the committee until after crossover so
you've got until uh end of March right
yeah crossover happens around the end of
March
yeah we probably won't schedule things
right away way because it takes a while
for them to get assigned to the
committee for